bonjour et bienvenue à jeun 2016 en
direct studio au diagonal tv avec arié
moins que le numéro 3 français laurent
freestyle et bonjour le rang bonjour
stéphane de titres au compteur de titres
quand on est donc en troisième ce serait
pas mal
un troisième ça serait ça serait très
bien voir c'est pas parti très fort
difficile alors déjà tu avais pas joué
l'an dernier c'était à 50 ha parce que
tu étais pris ta mais voilà j'étais le
champion d'espagne avec mon équipe
espagnole je joue depuis quelques années
pour eux et il leur manquait un joueur
donc voilà je laisse tomber un petit peu
si je jouais pas pour eux donc
commission sympathique les amis les amis
basques et même la maison des basques
jean pour l'équipe basque
voilà j'ai préféré privilégier mon
équipe espagnole il faut faire des choix
et alors cette année par contre c'est tu
es sur des terres puisque tu es en
aquitaine t'es pas si je crois par dax
d'ailleurs tu as fait un tour au sud de
dax j'ai fait j'ai passé une soirée aux
fêtes de dax où tout à fait branché
c'était raisonnable de croire le passé
trois jours voilà je fais c'est ma fille
chez mes parents
et j en passe après j'ai agi rabassa pas
le tournant a mis les fêtes continue
alors c'est terminé les fêtes mais je
veux passer quelques jours j'étais
manque encore des amis là-bas et et
voilà je passe toujours
je passe toujours du gothard net et
d'ailleurs on touche à gagner tu fais
une simultanée aussi
je crois ou régulièrement de faire
quelques simultanée la barre oui mais
plus trop maintenant l'année dernière
j'ai fait les 50 ans du club de mont de
marsan
oui voilà donc j'étais très heureux très
heureux qu'ils m'appellent pour venir
venir fêter ça ensemble c'était très
sympa et donc j'y retourne toujours avec
autant de plaisir et voilà je retrouve
des gens j'ai connu un an 25 ans voilà
qui organisait des tournois qui jouait
contre - voilà donc c'est toujours
toujours ça ravive d'être d'excellents
souvenirs d'enfant et oui parce que
laurent fois ci non seulement c'est un
des meilleurs français de l'histoire du
jeu d'échecs mais c'est aussi pour
l'aquitaine moment important puisque
c'est le premier grand maître
international qu'a pondu l'aquitaine
voilà libyenne de dax et il est très
fort vous le savez tous aujourd'hui donc
une partie très importante puisque tu
avait démarré son championnat avec cinq
parties nulles ont commencé à se
4 on commence à se poser des questions
sur la possibilité qu'ils jouent le
titre parce qu'on se disait il reste
plus que quatre partis maintenant c'est
maintenant ou jamais c'est ce que je me
disais déjà comme 2 me tiendront bon
toute façon il faut tant qu'il ya un
espoir et je me vais tout tenter donc
voilà finalement j'ai pas tellement en
retard unis points mais bon la situation
n'allait pas et pas franchement
favorable parce que j'ai encore de noir
mais bon on va essayer j'ai une petite
chance j'ai pas très bien je joue pas si
mal mais le problème j'y arrive pas il
ya deux parties que j'ai pas réussi à
conclure et sa wii ce genre de choses
contre gautelier demuth ça
l'ordinateur donc plus c'est le fait des
dégâts assez élémentaire et ça peut
coûter cher en fin de temps à quand on
fait les comptes
ouais c'est dommage mais bon faut pas
penser à ça et il faut regarder
voilà en tout cas ce qu'on avait vu dans
ton jeu indépendamment des résultats qui
vont qui pouvaient se questionner
effectivement c'est qu'on avait vu que
tu avais pas vraiment été en danger
jamais tout avait plutôt pris des
avantages et tu avais manque
effectivement une deux ou peut-être même
3 - 2 transformations qui visiblement te
pénalisé mais là aujourd'hui tu joues et
donc joueur surprenant on l'a reçu hier
dans les cieux de monatélé c'est jean
françois joly alors tu le connaissais
avant tu avais déjà joué avec lui il m'a
dit oh non
avec 60 c'était une grande première
bon il avait un point maintenant je suis
revenu à hauteur mais il avait un point
de plus que moi la partie donc s'était
pas franchement prévu mais pour lui et
on a discuté le petit pas pour la partie
était content de de comment ça se passe
pour lui bonjour pour l'instant je pense
que si on veut d'ici s'il faisait trop 3
me sur 9
il aura accepté leur a accepté tout de
suite
et voilà donc ils se c'est un très bon
joueur il défend bien même aujourd'hui
il avait une position
très compliqué quand on le verra après
ouverture est bon il s'est battu très
accrocheur est très accrocheur donc et
un moment je me suis vu pas gagné vers
la fin donc bon enfin il a joué un coup
de kessé vite qu'ils étaient pas qu'ils
me kerry qui était pas terrible ça
bordeaux d'après dans ses problèmes
physiques là je sais pas ça faisait
beaucoup de jeu beaucoup de coups qui
jouait train de se borner défend toute
la partie bon il craque je n'en veux pas
particulièrement d'avoir craqué en
suisse tu l'as eu un peu les yeux on va
regarder cette partie très importante
donc ça trop lance vraiment parce que
l'or dans les résultats pour dire un
petit mot on a peut-être en dire encore
à la fin mai christian bauer a perdu
donc du coup tu lui passe devant et
n'ont fait leur reviennent pour être un
oui c'est vrai tu reviens il ya deux
joueurs il ya deux joueurs qui ont 10
points de plus dans la longue on est
dans la situation est jugée ex-aequo
avec deux autres joueurs donc jean
françois joly et et et christian voilà
c'est ça mais tu rejoins le groupe de
tête et on peut dire que maintenant plus
est là pour jouer le titre je crois que
là tu es vraiment relancé trois rondes
3d est marrante qui vont qui vont être
cruciales
donc on regarde cette partie on n'a pas
regardé tous les coups parce que sinon
ça serait trop long mais peut-être les
moments les plus les lacs d'important
parce que sinon ça serait trop long et
c'est pas le but parce que tu dois jouer
demain et on n'a pas non plus diffuser
c'est pas donc au niger mais c'est déjà
fait alors donc tu as les blancs j avais
aucune idée mais c'est un peu bizarre
parce qu'il est il n'y a pas trop de
parties de ma faute si je crois qu'il
joue pas beaucoup
voilà on est c'est parti sont pas dans
la base je savais que j'avais aucune
idée de ce qu'ils aiment jouer au foot
avait vu ses parties précédentes
oui mais on n'a jamais joué des quatre
c4 en fait il a effectué trois derniers
nommés l'accession l'an dernier non on
n'est jamais fait des quêtes c'était
très bizarre
d'accord donc on c'est parti les
catalanes on l'a fait mais moi je
voulais pas faire une ktm
d'accord on entend tout et tu as choisi
dans ton arsenal richert joueuses et
agressif aujourd'hui donc dans be dame
voilà donc ça je crois que c'est l'arago
sinn
tout à fait on n'y est pas ce que
matthew cornette nous avons parlé dans
la
à dassa frère parti et on a vu ça ragot
sinn
alors donc je connais pas du tout ce
truc reprise prise c'est simple affiche
rock c'est un peu normal je vois justice
et noir mais bon pourquoi pas 3 ces cinq
là j'ai commis je vais vite j'ai voulu
sortir de là la théorie de la théorie ta
terre sainte a senti que peut-être il
connaissait déjà mais je vous rappelle
il ya beaucoup de parties ici un voilà
sur les ce système tu me connais avec
les blancs pas de problème non je
connais je connais je connais d'accord
je voulais être les noix donc faux de un
coup ou pas habituel coin mais pas mal
en général dans ce genre parce qu'il
pose une question noire c'est là
qu'elles ont qu'est ce qu'il faut et
leurs pions c'est alors est ce qu'ils
peuvent le ccap et du coup j'ai pas et
je perds pas mon temps avec montfort
détrempée oui j'allais à voilà voilà
il est donc illégal avait déjà eu deux
donc tue le tue le tue le tue moins huit
heures je vais faire fois deux tyrans
qu'est-ce qui fait avec ce en faisant du
coup j'ai passé de 30 mais j'ai changé
ff aussi ce qui est à mon avis pas idéal
mais mon cou un peu passif pour le fou
en tout cas
n'est pas une défensive ce point aussi
c'est donc là on voit tout de suite le
plus isolé au centre oui et donc là il
ajoute cette ligne de jeux en fait avec
les noirs sur animaux et james et 2000
j'ai économisé dame ces deux ordres
bref à quoi l'a donc là il ya deux
écoles on reprend en c5
même s'il reprend c'est ça que je crois
que juste rauque et il va y avoir
beaucoup de problèmes
et pourquoi enfin ce tour c'est un web
adobe je joue par exemple on est
d'accord on n'a pas très vilain n'ont
cessé leur foute renseigne donc tu as
envie de voir tout d'abord france et 5
et je vais rockets voilà maintenant
parce que notre club et la ccit source
est un pur c'est un bon niveau b 6 par
exemple méthode il ya quatre d'accord
voilà j'ai un pion isolées très agréable
il n'est pas du tout la tête il a pas
d'attaqué il va gérer poussé d'éclairage
la lui servent pas
il est cloué c'est vraiment pas terrible
pour les pâtes et riz tu va occuper
cette cale avec ceinture où tu vas
prendre éventuellement ici les belges
possèdent d'ailleurs je faisais au lieu
de couper si je sais qu'aider 4 tout de
suite qu'elle ait des cas tout de suit
et c'était une très bonne version d'un
pur isolé donc il veut pas vraiment
faire ça d'accord j'ai perdu du temps
ils sont fous des accords ont compris
des pensées qui joue l'autre option et
docks a et b 17 juin et à nontron pas
s'y prendre et il a pris d'abord il
prend d'abord je les prends d'abord
laisser l'autre option c'est de dire on
va créer des pions doublé et s'il ya des
récupérer quoi
voilà donc qui reprend et maintenant
quelle est cette il attaque c'est celle
menant à vue chrétien jamais celle de
reprendre rien ça c'est ça les curieux
dans cette partie
c'est à dire que là tu joues dam des
quatre qui protège et alors et c'est là
alors là c'est oui c'est un peu tendu on
se dit si je vous tour suite mais on
peut envisager ces six mois les métaux
reprend je pensais que c'était pour
prendre en prend 1,7 et il reprend à ces
trois donc tu auras tu as fait ça n'ont
jamais fait j'aurais fait petit à petit
robe tranquillement en attendant de
vente au français 5 et là j'aurais fait
d'un b 4 al anon b4 et leurs cavaliers
voilà je gagne un tempo et je joue mes
deux clients des 4 es tu mets ton fameux
donc en fait ton idée syriens de jouer
contre ce pion isoler le glauque en d4
et à la mi-temps pion de la pointe c'est
que je veux pas qu'ils reprennent par
exemple si j'ai fait petit rock
l'un des quatre au lieu de six il
reprend du cavalier en c5 et il va
mettre le cavalier en 1 4 oui ça c'est
ce que je veux pas moi j'ai envie qui
j'ai pas envie qu'ils reprennent qu'ils
puissent reprendre du cavalier ans et sa
mère de camille et un cas d'accord donc
c'est pour ça que je vous donne des 4 et
juste que j'aimerais éviter sa manoeuvre
donc damas cinq dames à 5 dmb 4 à mon
avis la dame s'est passé alors oui mais
dans mon cas ça a l'air d'être un bon
coup lors des français 5 et d'autre
alors on s'est dit ou adam prend 6,5
meur si fier d'un process and en prend
non j'aurais pas fait parce qu'on s'est
dit d'emprunt qu'elle les prend sous
prend un peu plus loin oui mais c'est
pas bon et je connaisse le bien en plus
ah oui là j'ai une position similaire
que j'avais déjà internet on comprend
qu'elle prend vous prend vous prends ça
leur corps là le gros problème pour les
noirs pour les blancs je suis très bien
stratégiquement mais j'ai pioncer trois
que je vais perdre oui mais sur les
fesses que tours fc huit cavaliers ou
quatre tours ses sept tours assez vite
et j'ai une faiblesse est gelée
finalement les pions doublé allait droit
je peux pas vraiment l'attaqué tout je
vais perdre un pion quand j'aurai pas
fait ça sur des français 5
ce que vous prévoyez 4 sur dawn princess
un brevet faux problème 6 tout de suite
c'est pas pareil voilà mais en l'idée à
oui parce que s'il prend d'abord la dame
évidemment tu reprends du curieux ça si
bien structuré unités + orange est élu
il avait aucune faiblesse et villepin
premier plan
la joc simplement et je vais jouer après
je gardais d'un mât il est obligé il est
obligé de prendre b4
parce que là c'est pas la même fête de
noël parce que tu as la place des quatre
tout de suite il prend b4 le prendre
mais quinze autres et puis on prend que
la vallée prend quand les profs ou voilà
je joue caïds et 4 et je connais mais
c'est depuis prochaine kroeff trois mois
des deux tournages c'est un oui il peut
peut-être
coût 2 à 4 à 5 ans et à prix fixe et le
roi aux saintes déjà il rompt la police
est hélas plus une faiblesse énorme plus
il a pas la colonie il apparaît enfin il
a disputé mais je peux faire à 4 à 5
poser question elle dame la courte et
bien
c'est quasi c'est quasiment un avantage
sans son accord mais bon hockey dans la
partie je pense qu'ils aient quasiment
sept ans qu'il revienne en tout cas
c'est un aveu de faiblesse que vous
donne ma chaîne m6 est sa part les
intrigues très efficace donc la petit
rock
ouais tranquille je pensais qu'il
effectue quatre y aura du oui oui on
s'est dits cavaliers au club tout de
suite avait l'air plus précis attaque le
fou parce que je vous ai fait que tout
sera revenu ou hausse est aussi fou 7
mai la a5 wallon c'est compliqué mais la
première c est plus compliqué il y avait
des choses
d'accord on s'est vite il n'a pas choisi
ça il l'a fait là j'étais content qu'un
cahier des 4 et là c'est bon il y ait ce
bloc
tu vas pouvoir refuse d'être
éventuellement tu peux tu menace de
devenir en bessin peut-être fait cavaler
aux 4 par exemple maintenant c'est
beaucoup moins fort je fais juste faut
être quatre ou f4 dame de france et 5
qui est paré l'agent mais cette série de
six le câble ministre en c3 les princes
mouais et le câblier plutôt pour
récupérer le dernier d'accord avec une
variante ici et x 6 x 6 et bien sûr quoi
6 où ça bloque pas de problème la dame
non parce que le fou contraire et ne
font contrôler tous cas ce qu'estime
menace cavale et prend fou qui on prend
et on perd le cavalier twilight avec une
grosse pression en fait il est coincé là
et ce cavalier magnifique c'est un peu
ça ressemble un peu à la partie mais
c'est d'accord ça paraît donc de
retracer cette nouvelle princesse ainsi
forte tu prends l'ancêtre dont 6 juin au
4 x 4 c'est là une transposition c'est
un peu la même idée mais il fait pas ça
il prend 1
or lui par contre une barre à quoi
mais où j'ai enfin pu obliger d'accord
et la fois ce cas très important mais tu
empêches détourbet 8 tu tiens les dames
quoi dire que la gamme v elle est à toi
tu gardes ton fou j'évite des cavaliers
aux quatre donc à noter que tu as quand
même la paire de fou et ça c'est très
important
il a en plus isolé on peut dire qu'une
plus isolé c'est une première faiblesse
la paire de fou c'est une deuxième
faiblesse et pas de coordination entre
les pièces une coordination un peu
discutable effectivement sur ces pièces
cassées cinq tables et c'est cette
attaque la dame a priori seul coup la
dame c'est un choix et pur dmbc mesdames
set j'étais content de mon temps mais
adam chef président saddam hussein oui
parce que l'idée c'est tours 8
sa survie ainsi l'avez-vous touristes
pour harceler la daf frais torah c'est
un bateau restait attention parce que
sinon ces dames transférer ferry
français et s'il prend sur 6 38 en train
d'apprendre tout reprend déjà fait les
deux aigles et de fou avec les dédales
colonnes un peu comme un peu mieux alors
beaucoup mieux en mieux passer à la
partie finale entame on ne voit plus les
tours cela s'est beaucoup là c'est juste
c'est quasi permanent réfléchi très
longtemps il y avait que 4 comprendre ce
soit pas très agréable donc il fait
qu'aller ce4 donc alors là j'ai au début
je voulais faire f3 sans réfléchir
c'est dangereux parce que tu affaiblis
tombe sur trois un peu quand même
et justement cavaliers h salle très
concret roissy parce que s'il a pas de
case voilà que ja je sais que c'est très
compliqué je sais pas salir et salir ses
très jolies parce que si je fais plus on
prend 2,4 alors si on prend en aucun cas
les premiers 4 r si je reprends du pion
il prend le cavalier sur l'échec et si
je prends la tour et il me prend la tour
1 a aussi où il peut prendre aussi ou
trois et peut prendre le 3e et même plus
mais l'atout que c'est pire en emmerdant
voiture oui c'est bien les deux où sont
les deux plus proches l'avenir
d'accord j'ai pas vu ouais bon si ça t'a
fait du puy en trois classes et autres
waka c'est au cadre d'un jardin x 6
finalement c'est pas mal voilà si on
joue aux trois on n'a pas envie que la
dame se traînent ici quand il faudrait
qu'il soit ailleurs j'ai serré ma
présence pour y poser des questions
enfin si ce qui l'intéresse que tu
bloques aussi le pion à cette nouvelle
rien et puis tu prends la deuxième case
de colonne ouais c'est à dire que là on
voit bien que les deux foules plus ils
regrettent parfois enfermé la torah 8
aussi enjoint font 17 et yahoo si sa
voix si c'est là qu'on voit la puissance
d'un père de foudre est aujourd hui nos
élites dames aux pressions ouverte en
plus vous avancez vers l'internal parce
que c'est la seule case correct dams et
7 parce que sinon excellent après de
trop longues un grand fou prend et ses 5
avait les essaims qui revient il attaque
le fou ouais j'ai deux foulées le seul
truc s'il faut je le faut je savais à
manouvrer l'a pas mal hein voila voila
ca à manoeuvrer sur les colonnes il va
situer en fait ton idée maintenant si
l'activité tour max sur les colonnes et
avec des fous et c'est de faire une
pression maximum sur sur l'a77 sur a7
sachant que son pion des cinq le gène
plus qu'autre chose c'est génial pour
ton cavale et des quatre qui aimons ce
qui est monstrueux il est énorme ce
cavalier imprenable inattaquable et ça
le gêne lui si en plus ce pion
l'empêchent de faire des choses points
donc voilà le jeu des blancs en fait
donc les normes ne peuvent être que
passifs
bon là j'ai résumé le truc les quatre
cavaliers ou quatre tours fc 1 ou
ingénieurs des choix même très bien
ah oui alors oui il y avait l'autre coup
je sais pas si tu avais pensé j'ai c'est
vrai bien sûr c'est bon ca faut 5 voilà
on a passé l'âge et 5
on avait en effet fait sens on a hésité
à en trouver jeu ça et aussi ce coup qui
l'a fait on combat - je pensais qu'il
s'agissait donc la foule et la rive six
foulées trop la haye et maintenant tu
reviens j'ai 3 alors l'idée c'est que
maintenant s'y prend oui parce que c'est
un peu l'idée de ce qu'il a fait là
voilà après maintenant il a créé une
faiblesse est finalement je vais faire h
grand âge sept
ouais d'accord ce que je vais faire tout
17 par exemple puisque je m'inspire
française entre mes mains je mène à des
taux en cavalier le fou était pas
défendu et je pense je vais faire f3 ou
g4 j'étais pas sûr pour 3g 4 le jeu mêle
d'euros f2
bref de étuve à l'attaqué ça je vais le
prendre non mais je vais combiner le
temps il a beaucoup de faiblesses il
peut pas je ne peux pas venir le roi au
centre parce qu'il va perdre son pied et
éventuellement tout rachid pourrait
attaquer nous as a service et 13 c'est
pas facile de voir si une faiblesse 5
parce qu'on n'a pas l'habitude d'aller
en finale aller chercher je vois pas ce
qu'il peut faire
est il possible descente sur la 7e il
suffirait qu'ils mettent une tour sur la
7ème et je faire pour ces deux projets
cloud oui mais tu peut pas à la fois
attaquer aguero a réussi par exemple si
je fais tour ces deux héros f2 et
tourache l'autre lors de notre trajet
taquet toujours à modeler tu vas bouche
louis tu vas tu va déstabiliser ce
cavalier
oui je vais essayer une autre faiblesse
et le front des droits et tu va taper
sur la chaîne il pourra pas défendre à
la fois la colonne c'est à la fois
j'allais être à la faute et c'est alors
je pouvais aussi échanger et s'est
échangé le fond f5 d'accord ici il s'est
affaibli en fait je pensais que c'était
à feluy non droit il avait une profonde
qu'aucun plan même jour jamais pensé que
c'était de faiblesse éthique donc ici
tours fc 1 et la callas non mais c'est
sûr tu penses nuc - la question se pose
pas se tromper aussi c'est
malheureusement ça arrive régulièrement
alors l'autre idée qui fait
effectivement c'est cavaliers
cavalli à 4 alors oui l'idée c'est comme
en mettant là on essaie de désorganiser
un peu les blanc et noirs voilà c'est
tout il ya que ça comme idée mais c'est
déjà bien ingénieurs si on a eu un effet
un gène humain c'est pénible mais
effectivement x 6 pose une question la
grippe va en prendre prise prise caisse
et celles selon lesquelles ces scènes
plutôt que ces 3 way s'est pas stable
c'est moi ça a l'air moins stable et ses
trois jeux faire tourner ces deux il
fait quoi pour chaque course et pas de
clergé faire f3 je vais bien et l'on f3
et si le roi tu va mener le royal mail
ou peut-être le fou aussi peut-être ma
tête avant d'être d'être et les
cavaliers sont pas stables c'est sûr
d'autant que tu le quotidien s'est vite
il avait l'air à s'activer eux c'est ça
le problème
donc là il attaque le fou contre bien
food ou des sept voiles il veut changer
une paire nice perd 2 pièces yves
jacques et aussi pour échanger et les
cavaliers c'est un cavalier une paire de
cavaliers il manquerait bien 1 psg
prétrole contenue en kf3 montus
l'empêchent définitivement devenu en
vingt quatre et tu donnes une petite
camargue est un peu long pour 6 buts
améliore tranquillement des pièces quoi
il a dit des six ans à lui permet de ne
pas bouger ça peut déjà il peut pas
bouger qu'est-ce que si j'ai changé tour
j'avais de contrôle et a cassé trois
donc j'ai envie de changer de diagonale
un mot tu veux contrôler cette case
ville met au fond de mes quatre voilà
parce que c'est quelqu'un une fois que
l'échangé tôt il ya pu y ait ces trois
semaines la vie à deux sa fenêtre à deux
et ils envisagent de te prendre bien de
jeu c'est pour ça que je le change de
diagonale d'accord encore voilà l'idée
qu'elle est mais c'est tout reprend
alors la seule
par contre c'est un tout petit peu
embêtant d'échanger les tours puisque
après fou prend la tacc du pion isolé
plus difficile sans détour pas tout à
l'heure on peut pas totalement
donc il a bien joué et n'a jusqu'à
présent et 4
il arrive à tenir quoi c'est pas se
perdre en gt j'espère donc sans doute
être inférieure à celle des grands
causses et permet un jeu parfait enfin
objectivement je pense qu'à présent les
jours à fait d'accord sur un jeu parfait
ses ternes à paris
non mais c'est un jeu objectivement
c'est comme ça que tu évolues une pause
et faire je sais pas si c'est dur
d'évoluer une position donc sous 17 dans
mes passions c'est clair que là il est
peu passif
indépendamment du gain ou pas il fait
que subir ils attendent les trois voilà
je voudrais pas qu'il remette son cas
hier ses cinq matches m
ouais tulle empêche de bouger quoi
touchons le coach tu sais quoi là-bas
cros gtc dominé les pièces ouais de
prendre place et 17eme place est
maintenant en bonne chose pour le
remettre en jeu donc il y est c'est de
replacer l'autre cas les v6 hop là c'est
toi qui propose un échange de pièces
pourtant le choix d'ailleurs lundi oui
j'ai hésité longtemps
j'étais pas sûr que je te faire fois-ci
souci voici cette fois ci vont les
prendre des lilas mètres de quais
l'alliance et 6 après c'est pas si
belles vaches locales et des véhicules
et cécile c'est caricatural ne gardez
pas facile à boire et à simplifier un
peu qu'elle est censée gagner en fait
c'est bien parce qu'on se dise ou qu'on
me dit bouge pas oui le seul classé 8
mais c'est quand même les objectifs à m6
et maintenant je préfère gagner mais en
fait il a trouvé fou d un l affût d
acheter l orifice alors il fait 6 passes
qu'il faut vite mais notre endroit bien
des endroits bien et voilà voilà
mais tu as joué un bon plan c'est pas
mal ça fou d 1 ha ça dépend si ça gagne
ou pas et voilà parce que ici pour
clouer ce truc là
et puis le cavaly peut pas bouger
toujours parce que yaz elle peut pas
bouger de cette façon donc je l'aï vu
jouer et j'aurais pu renier leurs 11 3
j'ai voulu que j'ai que je gagne 1,7
faudrait trouver 3 a l'air très bien
donc là par exemple s'ils jouent roi
aussi c'est fini le 4 way et va être
cruel donc il n'a pas le choix donc
l'intérêt c'est que en l'obligeant voilà
obligé de jouer il faut aussi s'il a
plus de coups parce que le roi ne peut
plus progresser
le cavalier ici
a parlé on s'est vite pour l'instant pas
grand choix c'est ce qu'il a fait chez
m&g c'est vrai que c'est franchement là
je crois que j'étais en fait je suis
génial c'est sûr mais il faut
transformer encore transformer en gros
f2 câblée civic seul coup à boire
et alors c'est pas facile on va voir
parce que bien qu'on progresse à veut le
ramener le roi bon bref
non mais c'est pas mal moins je le peux
dire c'est mal alors ça c'est le joli
oui alors il fait un bon plan parce que
mme évidemment ces deuils à décrire tout
c'est ça que j'aime l'univers le de
l'ata qui veut activer un petit peu son
cavalier mais émet de caliance et si
surtout crime bloqué voilà grâce et 6
pas pourquoi parce qu'il veut contrôler
les casinos ainsi pour empêcher le roi
soit d'aller vers des classes soit
d'aller en v4 et de l'empêcher de passe
qui dansent ils seront arrive à déborder
de ce côté là c'est moi c'est ça les
scellements pêché au niveau de ton péché
et alors là la finale le flou j'en sais
rien
ah oui tu pouvais prendre et jouer aux
dés 4 mini fée road et 6 jetez pas sur
ses pas sûrement sais pas sur quelles
étaient les fidèles de pions qui
s'annonçait pas encore clair ici et
après une autre une autre transformation
possible moi je pense qu'ici c'est pas
clair de parce que oui tu veux prendre
c'est un bon c'est une décision c'est au
38e coup un ouais je prends pas ce genre
de jeu c'est que l'autre qui va bloquer
il va venir en d6 lacunes se blesse
finalement cédé 5
parce que si c'est pas will ajoie 5e il
peut jouer à 5 voilà donc ça va être
bien je voudrais faire [ __ ] un airois
c3 c'est ça la belle eva ziegler même
pas vue d'un bon pas tout à fait oui
c'est un fait bien sûr vous prend rôles
c'est pour moi et je sais pas ce que tu
vas l'air thual à 1,5 et avait fixé ça
donc là il va jouer roi des six pour le
mans et on avait 4 ans d'écart et si je
vous passe y va non messieurs pas ci
fais ça et c'est par un processus ou 4
je crois qu'il attend il à top spin 3 5%
il fait pousser vite il fait fausse et 8
et maintenant et si je féroé 5-0 c'est
simple mais je peux faire tous ces deux
zèbres tous et de foot et trois pouces
et deux attaques h7 au passage
ça aurait fait quoi gistau 6-6 servir
mieux maintenant fou détroit 3 menacera
à 5 mg kg on ya plus important puisque
madame est là maintenant il peut faire
encore voici 6 ha ouais être les de
faire des cas n'ont pas leur pareil pour
sagan et tout de suite il peut pas de
salaire bon mais il faut pas se tromper
de coin tu fais trop c'est trop on sait
bien que j'aimerais mme simaïeva mais un
label weaving et ses six co les assises
et cette fois 417 çà et là ça fait
penser à la partie de maxime match à 9
contre vendres jouer aux olympiades
c'est exactement ça de fou combien aux
cavaliers ouais il a fait nul meteghan
il est interné il a raté les jeux je me
rappelle qu'il a c'était probablement la
même structure à un moment il devait
faire un fléau 4 pour justement activer
ces deux font donc c'est pour ça que
j'ai joué vite fous ces deux bons
joueurs cadres idéologiques doit faire
cinq pouces et 2 qui attaquent à me lie
à faire ça et 5ème adventures pour
limiter le fou est pour empêcher pour
empêcher le 4 il peut pas les empêcher 5
g si c'est un pied et c'est un rideau
courant essayé sur faisait trois fossés
vite
et oui je joue elle a joué le stonewall
le stonewall en finale de ce tournoi en
finale d'accord il est surveillé fou qui
est pas terrible
d'accord mais ça peut tenir franchement
je le redis six bombes et là c'est sous
des trois ne rien faire beau demain
c'est maintenant lâché là l'idée c'est
que finalement tu joues tu laisses
tomber l'idée du pion isolé parce que tu
te dis si ce centre saute ça ce pion
sottement rouennais couvre très fort
d'abord et huawei et le roi est
l'endroit le roi va aller comment on va
le voir que tu vas gagner de l'espace
pour des matchs parce que l'ajout montre
la supériorité il faut qu'ils voient là
donc il fait je jouais 4 ok c'est pour
ça qu'ils rêvent 5
je suis quasiment sûr je gagne de garder
un peu sur maxime moreau serré parce que
le cavalier peut encore s'en sortir tant
qu'il n'y a pas de vertus on est
actionnaire
il n'y a pas de donc là cavalier 5
pouces et 2 tu gardes le contrôle sur
mon gars tu veux pas non plus isolé
champions league ou de la 3c fait pas de
mal aux menaces attention puis en 34
vous prend à 2 à 3 ici h5 oui créés
contre je sais pas vraiment eu de
contrôle où il va encore y avait de quoi
déprimer la cie sacrifices et 4 pc si ce
n'est qu'elle est c'est si ce qu'elle
fout des trains les a pas peur
t'as pas peur de donner un fou parce que
la fin ne gagne un pion à une orange
arriver très vite rizla ça arrive vite
ce roi va aller beaucoup plus vite que
le roi je le dis pour nos spectateurs
quand même va aller beaucoup plus vite
que ce roi la hâte en jeu le juste c'est
pas bon pour voilà
je te parle c'est comme avec toi qu'il
faut voir que moi et ce roi va aller
beaucoup plus vite que celui là sur
l'est on va prendre ce client et ceux
qui ont passé c'est très très fort mais
on peut même faire dame sans que
l'adversaire puisse empêcher
on va empêcher l'adversaire même de se
sacrifier contre le pion souvent
extrêmement difficile à arrêter les
pions comme ça donc ici surtout comme
pluton fou de la bonne couleur
voilà un fou prend attaque le cavalier
il s'accroche s'accroche crochets ont
été incroyables comme il s'accroche
moi je viens là c'est bien c'est donc la
double arche compte un fou 17 à la route
un bon c'est un bon coup et la foulée 3
il y avait juste un truc attend ici
crois que c'est on se demander si nous
c'est que c'est non c'est pas là c'est
très bon jeu c'est plus un chat tout
c'était à l'aï fait à 5
oui oui food est à ouidah corps fait
alors qu'est ce qui peut faire d'autre
peut faire rien parce que si c'est fou
ces huit souris faire un petit coup
d'échec dame en anglais pour notre série
bones en relation les maîtres leroy g7
ouais tu est et ouest hérault à ses 5 et
après moi c'est 5 avec invasion d'accord
donc là cinq échecs et là tu peux pas
prendre puisque et une fourchette
voilà la solution sa spécialité la vraie
la spécialité les spécialités landaises
du médoc
mais bon ici la fourchette mais oui la
fourchette très fournie pour les
charmants et donc tu attaques qui
attaquent le fou le fou ici bien sûr
donc 3,5 forcé et là ils attaquent
attaqua exception je sais pas ce que je
cherchais obligé sinon il peut avoir des
sacrifices sur la france ils siègent pas
s'il trouve pas des contres jeu il
avancé plus tôt
donc j'y vois là vous éloigner le roi
voilà c'est ici on s'est demandé si la
finale n'était pas gêné rentes ne sais
pas pourquoi j'ai pas fait tout ce que
tu renvoies là je veux c'est gagner mais
je sais 3 ici oui je sais bien voilà
c'est ça que je recherchais on s'est dit
tous ces trois là rue gagner parce qu'on
s'en moque qui prennent ici prize-money
kg c'est ici fait je lui fais un petit
co2 il peut faire corriger 6
mais dans ce cas là tu prends le
quintuple champion ok h4 ah oui je suis
un gagneur j'ai calculé en plus j'ai
trois oui mais j'ai trois il va
peut-être
prendre un but sur shing non mais c'est
le problème parce que le curage le
cavaly suffit jamais arrêté un pur ou
non mais sérieux
layton et le roi il faut par exemple
s'il fait s'il fait voilà vas-y léger 3
alors j'ai trois ça on peut se tutoyer
pénétrer prend alors sous prend il faut
faire comprendre ici droit prend
cavaliers à 4 à 4 et 4 oui à 4 en coop à
4 pour gagner du temps et donc la roi il
faut un pour les manger bio maintenant
qu'est ce qu'il fait mais ils sont pas
en plus parce que c'est plus sournois
qu'est-ce qui fait ce qu'il peut faire
qu'est ce que tu vas chalet d'un mais le
problème c'est que cette position
tous les coups viennent il faut si je
gardais les fous je lui prendre et puis
c'est pas mal ce coup là oui
alors messieurs gmc comme le joueur de
tennis qui est des balles de match oui
mais répétition et c'est facile fait
cavalier hocine tu prends tu prends et
puis on prend fou prend c'est fini pas
surréagi 4 km
non mais sérieux que ça non mais là tu
prends choisi jean cavalier ou cinq ici
pariente kabze comprend cavaliers
comprend on prend le fou mais maintenant
je comprends pas le fou tu crois pas non
on voit déjà choix des sacrés je joue à
80 et demi tout va la perdre et alger
karaoui à j-4 après et je peux atteindre
mais il faut pas avoir des soucis oui je
pense d'accord je trouve pas je peux pas
je peux te le confirme donc s'il fait
qu'il ya eu 5 oui oui c'est pas si oui
comment ses amis je veux garder les fous
j'ai joué toute la partie pour les faux
je le gardais les fous tu vois mon cas
les scènes c'est encore un peu compliqué
on est d'accord ou alors tu prends le
fou on reprend on reprend et après tu
suis fou prend ici quel point m oui mais
depuis on ce tempo j'en sais rien je le
perds que je ne veux pas calculer tout
cas tu veux pas calculer
non mais regarde non mais c'est chaud
maintenant dans cette voie jo temps
autant prévient d'accord d'accord
d'accord parce que lecavalier leroy
menace de revenir en 17 ans
je tenterai je suis pour autant pris la
corde à coire et la position que j'ai
jamais croire quelques des choses qui
joue un thème pour d'accord non mais
c'est intéressant de savoir si le calcul
pas autant tu te dis la potion est trop
trop forte en fait quand je vois quelque
chose qu'il ya bien longtemps près et
pas sur ses pattes en l'air d'accord
donc floue b5 donc là tu gardes tu es
fou mais quand on sait ce qu'on s'est
dit bon on peut faire regarder ce qu'il
ya quatre à quatre quand je vais fixer
ce que tu fixes le fion tu le fixe voilà
ça c'est fait mais bien sûr on vous
attend sur cette pénible quand même j'ai
trois mois tu veux pas qu'ils qui joue
h3c ça je veux pas qu'ils fassent kf4
edf 4 je sais même pas pourquoi je pense
voilà je sais pourtant principe oui si
c'est un principe est forcément très
intelligents ici d'accord et la hep 5
mai après six heures de jeu avec cinq
minutes appelant nul ne sait jamais hein
c'est clair pousser 4 alors l'idée de
pousser 4 c'est de libérer la case p55
voilà et puis tu m'avais des bandes est
relevé
oui cavaliers aux 7 prend le calice et
un bon plan aussi là j'aurais pu prendre
encore ces 3 et la wii là ça marche
parce que l'eia plus délicate
je t'ai pas suivant c'était pas sûr
primagaz il faisait encore vers des
objets et pièces chic et c'est toujours
plus facile bien sûr on va prendre on va
prendre un temps fou ces trois mettant
f4 il fixe le pion pour essayer de le
gault besson carlos donc cela et je
mangeais 4 112 kg 6 ici donc qu'à
valider s'il va venir là et ça va être
pénible c'est notamment la prius 4k
voyage 4 maintenant on s'en doute
peut-être fou des huit pas sur premières
balles et l'obliger de prendre
maintenant on pousse mois 17 et il a
l'air de
alors voix 17 je pousse il peut pas
prendre le fou trois cvt france est vite
et il sait bon roi des fous si ça marche
pas on voit b 6e qui va te prendre un
échec alors à b6 b8 menace à 8,1 en
garde fou est là si je veux bien faire
danser nul quoi ah oui parce qu'il va
bouffer le dernier plus en plus on a
vécu en plus il peut même de l etat le
fou de la mauvaise couleur et la poisse
fait rien à faire à la fois jusqu'au
bout et met l'accent sur gaffe
bien sûr la non mais ces quatre essais
et pointe du matin c'est parce que je
veux j'ai cache pas c'est qu'ils ont
prévu quatre gagné honnêtement
ah oui non c'est pas clair c'est pas
clair parce que l'on prend effet ces
trois moyens n'est plus aussi c est fou
c'est 3 parce que je suis prend 1,5 et
c3 et ariane 4 qui est faible oui mais
on se dit attention attention à on s'est
dit que vous pouvez faire la pression
là-dessus c'est à dire qu'il va jouer
ici ça lui de jouer là il joue d'abord
food et c'est vrai c'est pas mal fondées
saint cloud prend voilà fou prend
ensuite il enlève le fou ou alors jour
peut-être n'ont-ils va pas jouer roi la
passe et dangereux je ne sais pas où
elle en joue deux fois huit comme ça ils
contrôlent le truc et la mlg de fer fou
des huit sous des 8 alors là maintenant
cavalier g6 et ja c'est la magie de la
paire de faux médiums et dureront actifs
roi des 6ème et domination mais par
domination à la veille de la nomination
il ne faut faire gaffe parce que sinon
le cavalier donné rajouter de la
pression rénovation mais j'ai vu que
c'est ça gagner le problème c'est que
les deux gagnent mais leurs six avions
plus sur la corde apprendra qu'on est un
peu plus fatigué je cadre mais je
conserve fou 17 pour commencer à te dire
merde non non non food et un homme aient
lâché une hallucination mais je pense
que je gagne encore frédéric et jessica
et des mauvais moments c'est pas bien
sûr des gones est évident dit pas de
mauvais mourant n'y pas grand monde sauf
sauf à d'un exceptionnel ça peut arriver
donc
issifou déjà bah oui il faudrait obliger
obligé mais oui tu vas pas donné
concurrents alain on est d'accord
hélas là il l'a fait la ccva life est un
très mauvais coup là il abandonné peu
après on est d'accord ou c3 je vais
maintenant ils ont saccagé 6 alors voilà
et dont il a chez millions 300 kg 6
alors qu'est ce qui fait qu'avec ses six
mois j'ai pensé faut ces trois quarts
blessé six avaient une idée de jeu
t'embête jeu complet a atteint
est-ce que je te fais chier d'abord ou
pas fou c'est trop on va dire amoureux
des cistes non ces troubles ont poussé
trois attaques à cinq mais ses protégés
pour l'instant donc voilà il fait chier
pas moins peut-être que te faire recette
brandissent suisse tu vas le faire mais
je vais faire rebaisser si j'ai envie
donc il fléchit pas moi en fait c'est
facilement mais je sais pas ce que j'ai
je n'avais peut-être faire flot de
trouver 5
alors il va admettons qu'ils fassent 3e
7e 2 dans ce cas là tu veux faire
pourquoi faut deux parce que enfin battu
vesa 17 fourbe et celle du coup ça va tu
es seul actionnaire nous serons sûrs
trucs et après c'est fini
oui ça leur but faire quelque peu pareil
que la partie donc il suffit n'en ai
fait qu'il ait atteint que j'ai 6 kg 6
qu'est-ce que j'ai j'aurais fait
n'importe quoi alors fou d un qu'avait
léger si si si je calcule en fait trois
des six à mes cheveux soient jamais on
est jeune on est bien avancé 3 au regard
de ce que je regarde c'est ce que je
regardais tous et 3g gi joe - de panique
fut c33 inc et h quatre cavaliers h4
bien sûr première pression sur f3 il
faudrait pas que ce fou viennent
augmenter donc là tu prends ouais faut
prendre un peu la parvenir ans et 6 pour
l'instant pour un clac nancy fait
d'accord nous fait tout un tapage accord
c'est quand même chaud parce qu'il va il
m'a bouffé le mail est de fous
malheureusement m
j'y serai encore oui
ouais donc il faut pas le genre note ça
doit être gagnant encore mais gagner on
est difficile hein parce que là il est
encore de lyon j'ai eu un coup de
panique quand j'ai vu ça mais en fait
j'aime rêver si non j'ai vu que j'avais
trois des six surtout aux listes ou c3
ici la c3 et je fais trois des six tu
fais plutôt tu penses que c'est mieux
parce que ça aille un peu ça a l'air
sympa parce que il fait l objet de faire
re des six îles de 8
il peut pas faire comme h 4 ça marche
pas là j'attaque le fou bayer mais sur
donc il fait fou
c'est le 1 800 doute je peux te faire un
coup des chèques tu vois des 3 bien sûr
je sais que ça fait pas sa manche
n'était pas sûr
j'enlève le contrôle donc roy hill fuite
forcée n'y a pas d'autres coûts c'est le
seul que j'ai maintenant il faut aussi
ce faux aussi ça leur manquait h4 oui
mais vous dire qu'elle dominait ce fait
là est la même pour prend 1,4 à mios
pour moi assez gagnaire vas-y vas-y il
va jusqu'au bout faute 6 alors fou et 6
kaige quatre ans tacle là aussi de
maîtriser un tremblement je peux faire
vous prendre le sac vous pourrez être à
temps pour manger sain atteint on est en
train de rater ma tante de la foux
pranger 5e épreuve trois jolies le match
de nice le vat de dax oui mais ça c'est
le match de dax
vi non mais le max de d'ascq se doute
parce que
oui celui-là il est spécial quand même
si spécial belle domination avec le fou
1,8 oui c'est vrai que là la vache oui
il bon c'est gallien on est il faut un
corps est possible évidemment il m'a
choqué c'est vite qu'ils étaient
simplifie ses trois médailles de plus
contre je prends le pion en plus j'ai
peut-être passer par des huit pour lui
attaqué j'ai 5 passage louis et métal et
je vais pousser plus loin enfin bon ben
arfa sont maintenant le plus grand
domaine très fort mais c'est vrai que
c'est chaud parce qu'heureusement tas
d'options contre 2 encore aussi bien sûr
s est pas mal de faire chez 4g gâte
c'est bien de garder les pions
effectivement parce que vous allez donc
j'ai jamais les vraiment laissé
s'échapper le non jamais
mais un peu hésitant quand même nom mais
ce président c'est qu'il a très bien
défendu je pense que il est aussi
accrocheur il a il avait toujours un peu
des deux un bien sûr c'est un mélange
des deux c'est par une belle partie je
prends encore une fois c'est dans
l'allée des parties précédentes sauf que
cette fois tu as réussi à transformer
avec un avantage en finale voilà
syndicats c'est beau parce que pour la
fin du tournoi on semble que telle
acquatella rater derrière et bombay la
pression va monter sur tous les
participants et pour nous spectateurs
public
c'est génial d'accord je te remercie
merci laurent la cie stéphane c'était
laurent frayssinet pour la 127e fois sur
la diagonale tv la superstar des échecs
français et aussi à qui tu aimes bien
entendu pour tous les aquitains qui sont
bien sûr très attentif au parcours de
notre champion local et international
merci laurent bientôt la prochaine
émission ni gonaté vie mais sur sur ce
national 2016 à agen au revoir